again okay we move on
it's uh
i i spoke about h6 and twitter so i'm
gonna use the first
chance that i get obviously to to play
it
um yeah as i said i'm still up two games
so i'm not
i'm not massively concerned here but
yeah the sweep is not on anymore
and uh in general
it's a little bit unpleasant to not to
win games that you
probably should have won
okay and now i don't know what to do
though
you could have gone bishop h4 and if i
go bishop b7 there's
an e3 and we have standard queen's
gambit
okay i think i'll just chop off
that bishop on g3 and go dc4 then c5
let me just go queen e7
probably want to go dc4 and then c5 but
maybe only after
only after he has spent one move
um and
it may look a bit tricky to open the
the h file here but i don't think it's
it's a major issue
okay let me go root the 8 button
cd ed
i think he's just going to follow it in
up in a pretty standard way here
could have got knight defense one but i
don't think that was
so great okay let me go for
c5 now i have the chance
the point is dc5 i'm going to go d4
and uh then he has to go knight d1 but
then and you move
like knight c6 or whatever should be
fine for me
so he castles but now
i think i'm in principle quite all right
the only question is whether i should be
ambitious by going c4
i don't feel like it though
or do i no i don't feel like it
let's just go knight c6
taken c5 i guess it's a little bit
better
but i very much like the fact that he
has these double pawns and
on uh on the g file it means that
my uh knight or bishop has a square in
g4 don't think i should trade queens
quite yet here
um yeah so i have a little bit of a
foothold on on g4
and um that i think
may may help me
okay so he insists on the exchange of
queens
yeah i don't think i can do anything
about it so let me just
acquiesce to that um rook c8
if we're kc1 i got knight before well
there's bishop b1 so that's not an issue
for him
a3 is very sensible as well
basically i'm just a little bit worse
but
i'd be lying if i said i was majorly
concerned
but as usual my time my time expenditure
is
a little bit on the on the dubious side
knight c5 i'm just going to go rook c7
don't really see a major issue there
yeah okay i'm i'm regretting the whole
c5 thing
that's because this position is just so
uninspiring
uh not so sure about what he did there
though
he has a track rook seven now there's
not b7
which may not be the end of the world
okay let me go 985 he has tricks icon
tricks as well
95 so if he takes i take a d1 and
yeah i don't
don't think i have any problems there
knight c4 knight b7
mp2 knight d8 91
yeah i think so b6 then
on knight p3 i guess it's
likely then i go knight c4
and i should be fine
a little bit worse but fine
we're both just burning time for
whatever reason in this game
well knight d3 that is surprising
let's see foreign d4
i guess i'll take it instead
obviously pretty dull
yeah i should in general not put the
pawns on
light squares but i think it's fairly
justified when he gets the
weakness on g3
in general this should be a fairly
standard draw
although he's of course slightly better
even after this move he's slightly
better i think
but probably not now now my king is
is active and this could be one of those
karpov games right where he says
yes you are indeed slightly better but
soon i will be slightly better
yeah i think e4 was was a step in the
wrong direction
maybe he felt he felt the need to do
something
but doing nothing is
fairly often better than doing something
now i'm probably just
much better okay
go with the bishop to a4 well i'll just
go knight c4 in fact
no knight c4 is king of two and knight
e3 so we go respect
fish
what you're going to do
now i think i'm just much better
go a5
here we go a4 he has
very little power okay
f6 restricting him even further
bishop c8 p4 this bishop b7
so we go this way
yeah he's gonna try and lock me up
but i think i'm fine
king is not completely caught
uh oh there's knight g8 i thought bish
b4 was easily winning but i should go g5
then
f5 now this can't be any good
i'll just push
page three should be the end of the game
okay let me just be
extraordinarily cruel here and
just
[Music]
i'm not even gonna bother with this one
because i'm
i just want to go and capture the
unfortunate trapped steed over there
okay that was um that was okay i think
uh i guess i sped up at the right time
and showed some decent technique